[Music]
you're about to see Disney Princesses
like you've never seen them before
a few creative artists including Micah
Graham Robbie Cooke and Isaiah case
Stephens games the princesses some
incredible superhero makeovers just wait
until you see what Bell looks like as a
green-skinned she-hulk if you're new to
our channel don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today
we'll be sharing 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined as superheroes
Mulan who says you have to be royalty to
be a Disney Princess Mulan is proof that
even though she wasn't born or married
into nobility she's just as deserving of
the Prince's title the toughest Nell's
fighting warrior is known for her
heroism and her bravery so we wouldn't
be surprised if she was an undercover
superhero to be honest you've seen her
do those high-flying kicks right she
definitely has what it takes to kick
some butt artists Robbie Cooke made it
his mission to redesign the
free-spirited character into a superhero
are you ready to see her here she is
Mulan has been reimagined as none other
than the x-men character Psylocke just
check out her costume pretty amazing
right the traditional Chinese outfit
Mulan usually wears has been replaced by
psy Locke's one-piece bathing suit and
strappy boots she also wears the x-men
characters signature bands around her
upper arms and judging by the look on
Millan's face she's ready for action
if Mulan were a superhero what do you
think her superpower would be let us
know down below in the comment section
and guess what you might even get a
reply from us Pocahontas Pocahontas the
Native American princess has beautiful
jet black hair and stunning physical
features seriously just check out our
cheekbones and lips she's absolutely
flawless when Pocahontas was revealed
the world back in 1995 Disney fans were
so excited to see a little bit of
diversity thrown into the mix she was
the first Native Disney princess added
to the lineup and her gentle nature and
kind heart made her one of the most
popular animated characters even though
we think Pocahontas is beaut
full exactly the way she is we'd still
love to see her as a superhero wouldn't
you well
artists Ravi cook has come to the rescue
once again here's Pocahontas reimagined
as x-23 since she was created using
Wolverines DNA this is definitely one
superhero you don't want to mess with
just check out her retractable claws
those can really do some damage as the
Marvel Comics character Pocahontas has
the ability to repair and restore
damaged tissues much faster than the
ordinary human wouldn't it be cool if
Marvel comics teamed up with Disney for
an x3 movie starring Pocahontas we
definitely be the first in line at the
movie theater to watch her in action
mogera when you think of an independent
and strong-willed Disney character
mogera is probably at the top of your
list as Hercules his love interest in
the 1997 animated film meg keeps the
main character on his toes at all times
she's just a little bit bitter when it
comes to men her past experience has
made her half a tough exterior but on
the inside she has a heart of gold even
though as she was cynical when it came
to relationships
Hercules never gave up on her these two
were definitely what we would call
relationship goals we can see why
Hercules fell in love with her she's a
very attractive Greek beauty but aren't
you curious to see what she would look
like with a superhero makeover artist
Isaiah case Stephens went to work on her
image and he turns Meg from a Disney
princess into Catwoman as the DC Comics
character Meg where's Samantha hi boots
and a skin-tight cat suit that fits like
a glove she can't have a bunch of
clothes getting in her way when she's
performing her acrobatic and martial
arts stunts and of course her outfit
wouldn't be complete without her
facemask and her cat ears how awesome
does she look Cinderella Cinderella was
born with natural beauty and it was her
good looks that got her into a lot of
trouble in life
her stepmother was so jealous of her she
would go out of her way to treat
Cinderella poorly even though her life
was less than ideal after the passing of
her biological mother and father the
Disney princes always remained humble
and kind this is why she's one of the
most popular Disney characters to date
she's very feminine and we
couldn't imagine her even harming a fly
she's just that sweet but it's about
time the princess received a new look
thanks to artist Micah Graham Cinderella
has been reimagined as Batgirl as the
daughter of Gotham City's police
commissioner Batgirl is skilled in judo
and karate wouldn't it be awesome to see
Cinderella use her martial arts skills
against crooks and criminals we think so
while wearing the Batgirl costume
Cinderella keeps her hair and an updo a
lady has to remain elegant at all times
of course she wears the signature
Batgirl costume along with a cape and
eye mask and her pointy ears but even as
a crime-fighting superhero Cinderella
remains true to herself by wearing her
glass slippers at all times
Belle Belle always stood out in her
small French village she was much
different than everyone else
she had an intense fascination with a
reading and she didn't like to follow
the crowd she loved to do her own thing
and this made her feel left out and like
an outsider but when she met Beast she
not only found a friend
she found a partner who understood her
even though the relationship wasn't
always smooth selling Belle taught Beast
how to love when it comes to her
appearance Belle is absolutely gorgeous
and she's definitely one of the most
beautiful Disney Princesses ever she has
brown hair and big brown eyes she
typically wears a blue sleeveless dress
with a white long-sleeve shirt
underneath a white apron and brown flats
her brown hair is usually worn in a low
ponytail that's high back with a blue
ribbon but we think it's time to see
Belle in a new light don't you agree
well artist Robbie cook gave Belle a new
look that will shock you are you ready
to see her here she is as Marvel Comics
character she-hulk she has a brand new
body including some pretty massive
muscles we would love to see Belle put
those muscles to use and show us just
how strong she really is Tiana we know
we weren't the only ones who were
excited when Disney announced this new
character back in 2009 tiana became the
first african-american disney princess
when the princess in the frogs debuted
the hard-working animated character has
a very busy schedule and she spends most
for free time working in the film she
has dreams of opening a restaurant but
we think
have a better career path for her just
like the rest of the princesses on our
list
Tiana also received a superhero makeover
that you have to see to believe
here she is artist Micah Graham revamped
the princess from head-to-toe she's
leaving the streets of New Orleans
behind to become Hal Jordan better known
as the Green Lantern how amazing does
she look at her green outfit and her
white gloves as the comic book character
Tiana is skilled in boxing wouldn't you
love to see her go head-to-head with a
crook as she fights crime let us know if
you would watch a Green Lantern movie
Styne Princess Tiana down below in the
comment section and you never know your
comment just might get pinned to our
Channel Rapunzel in the 2010 film
tangled Disney lovers were introduced to
Rapunzel she instantly became a fan
favorite thanks to her 70 feet long hair
her quick wit and her feisty personality
in the animated film Rapunzel spends
most of her time trapped inside a tower
she wears a traditional German outfit
consisting of a purple pink and white
dress it has puffy sleeves and a lace on
the hem it's difficult to imagine
Rapunzel looking any different from the
way she appears in this film but hardest
Micah Graham didn't disappoint us he
decided to redesign the Disney Princess
and completely transform her look are
you ready to see the superhero version
of Rapunzel take a look at her now her
beautiful dress is long gone because
Rapunzel is now none other than flash
known as the fastest man alive
slash spends most of his time fighting
against the wicked people in the city
Rapunzel wears his signature costume and
just look at her long hair blowing in
the wind as she races down the street as
fast as she can we hope her hair doesn't
get in the way when she's out there
fighting crime snow white snow white
made her debut way back in 1937
she's now considered to be one of the
most iconic animated characters ever she
has a very childlike personality and
it's her sweet and innocent nature that
makes her vulnerable to outsiders her
wicked stepmother is jealous of her
natural beauty so she does whatever she
can to bring Snow White down despite her
unfair living conditions the princess
always remains
cheerful and very sweet to the Seven
Dwarfs and the forest animals when you
think of this Disney character you
probably think of her signature court
dress with its high collar and puffy
sleeves well we're about to show you a
photo of Snow White as a superhero
and we know you're going to be amazed
ready here she is
Snow White is now Supergirl as a member
of the Justice League
Snow White now where's the comic book
characters signature outfit the letter S
is proudly displayed on her chest and
her red cape matches perfectly with the
red bow in her hair what do you think of
Snow White being reimagined as a
superhero
do you love her new appearance as much
as we do Jasmine in 1992 we all fell in
love with Princess Jasmine from the
animated film Aladdin the princess II
was born in a Middle Eastern Kingdom has
a tough time at home in the film her
father treated her like an object so she
spent most of her childhood dreaming
about breaking free from his control she
couldn't stand the strict laws of the
kingdom but as a superhero Jasmine would
be able to come and go freely and she'd
be able to help those in need at the
same time if you could turn Jasmine into
any superhero which one would you choose
well artists Robbie Cooke wanted to see
what Jasmine would look like if he
transformed her into Elektra do you want
to see her new appearance here she is as
the Greek superhero jasmine is skilled
in martial art and she also has the
ability to borrow people's minds and
acts through their bodies if Jasmine
could really turn into a lecture for a
day whose mind do you think she would
take control of first let us know your
thoughts down below in the comment
section we can't wait to see what you
have to say Ariel
if you're a cartoon lover you're
probably a fan of Ariel The Little
Mermaid star is everyone's favorite sea
creature and there's a good reason why
she's headstrong adventurous and very
loving
Ariel's also very compassionate and this
makes it easy for her to get along with
fellow sea creatures like flounder and
Sebastian as a mermaid area wears a
purple clamshell bra her mermaid fin and
not much else we've grown to love the
way she looks but there's nothing wrong
with giving her a bit of a makeover
right are you ready to see the Disney
Princess reimagined as
Bernier Oh check out Ariel now artist
Robbie cook removed her signature outfit
and dressed her up as Firestar as the
superhero Ariel can go wherever her
heart desires Firestar has the ability
to reach and Reiki which enables the
superhero to fly now that Ariel is able
to go airborne where is the first place
she thinks she would visit wouldn't it
be awesome to see her fly to the heart
of New York City
talk about a complete culture shock
Ariel would be completely out of her
element her time in the big city would
definitely be entertaining to watch
which of these Disney Princesses
reimagined as superheroes are your
favorite react in the comments section
down below
if you enjoyed this video and you'd love
to see more just like it don't forget to
subscribe and give us a big thumbs up
thanks for watching
[Music]
you